[Musik]
ein neues team für europa das
eu-parlament bestätigt die kommissare
und morena von allein verspricht einen
neustart ein urteil für viele
verbraucher wird zum beispiel mit ärger
ohne eigenen rechtsanwalt lösen will
kann sich von internet diensten helfen
lassen und ein comeback für jürgen
klinsmann der ex-bundestrainer wird
neuer coach bei hertha bsc
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend in allen
schön dass sie dabei sind wie auch
norbert leben und für den sprechenden
tor von mir
ursula von der leyen kann loslegen mit
überraschend deutlicher mehrheit hat das
eu-parlament ihrem team zugestimmt in
den letzten wochen noch hatte es drei
kandidaten abgelehnt und damit die
amtsübernahme verzögert mit dieser
mannschaft tritt ursula von der leyen am
sonntag ihren dienst an mit ihr größtes
projekt ist der kampf gegen den
klimawandel
bis 2050 soll europa der erste
klimaneutrale kontinent werden
verantwortlich dafür ist eine ihrer
stellvertreter der niederländer frans
timmermans aus straßburg hat und nur
sekunden liegen zwischen anspannung und
erleichterung
mit breiter mehrheit gibt das parlament
grünes licht für die neue eu-kommission
ursula von der leyen wird die erste frau
an der spitze der behörde und verspricht
spitzenleistungen
dazu gehören mehr forschung mehr
digitalisierung eine starke wirtschaft
allen voran eine ambitionierte
klimapolitik klimawandel geht uns alle
an
wir haben die pflicht zu handeln und die
macht zu für konkrete pläne wie sie
schon in der kommenden woche vorlegen
dann muss sie auch farbe bekennen wie
das alles finanziert werden soll
den einen ist der grüne deal nicht grün
genug die anderen fordern
er muss auch rot wird diesen grünen deal
den finden wir eine gute zeit ansage
aber leider hat sie gleichzeitig
angekündigt dass man in der
landwirtschaftspolitik und in der
handelspolitik eigentlich nicht zu
ändern will wenn wir sehr sehr
ambitionierte programme machen
gleichzeitig aber die menschen mit den
folgen alleine lassen zb
arbeitsplatzverlust dann wird das am
ende zurück schlagen da die briten
keinen kommissar stellen hat die neue
kommission nur 27 mitglieder
zwölf frauen und 15 männer ganz so
paritätisch wie versprochen
ist das nicht
kritik gibt es auch an personal man
befürchtet interessenskonflikte der
ungar salat erweiterungskommissar die
rechtsstaatlichkeit der kandidatenländer
überwachen
der franzose ex geschäftsführer eines
unternehmens kümmert sich um industrie
und digitales und doch hat die mehrheit
des parlaments für diese kommission
bestimmt schon gibt die chefin den ton
an und sagt heute abend wird gefeiert
heute abend wird gefeiert aber dann
müssen alle ran ursula von allein hat
einen neustart für europa versprochen
anne gellinek was wird denn neu ja die
neue von der leyen kommission wird
weiblicher klimafreundlicher und
digitaler als alle anderen eu kommission
vor ihr
sie wird vermutlich aber auch teurer als
alle anderen eu kommission vor ihr
und das könnte für ursula von der leyen
noch zum problem werden sie hat den
klimaschutz tatsächlich auch heute in
ihrer rede zur obersten priorität
erklärt der über allen anderen ressorts
stehen soll
und das wird so viel ist klar geld
kosten geld das zumindest teilweise aus
den eu mitgliedstaaten also auch aus
deutschland kommen wird die aber weigern
sich bislang einen höheren beitrag
künftig an die eu zu zahlen
erst war von der leyen ja gar nicht als
kandidatin von diesen posten vorgesehen
und es gab durchaus auch unmut im
parlament über ihre nominierung hat sich
das gelegt
ursula von der leyen hat verstanden dass
die nominierung ihrer nominierung durch
die staats- und regierungschefs das
parlament hier vor den kopf gestoßen hat
und sie hat die letzten wochen genutzt
um durch europa zu jetten um möglichst
viele europa parlamentarier und
möglichst viele staats und
regierungschefs zu treffen und das
überzeugende ergebnis von heute ist wohl
auch ein resultat dieses tourismus den
sie in den letzten wochen hier
veranstaltet hat ob ihr das für die
zukunft helfen wird ist aber fraglich
ich fürchte sie wird sich für jeden
ihrer vorschläge
neue bündnispartner hier im parlament
suchen müssen die einschätzung aus
brüssel von anne gellinek vielen dank
klimaschutz digitalisierung migration
auf von der leyens team warten viele
baustellen wer macht was in der neuen eu
kommission die köpfe und eine
beschreibung ihrer aufgaben
finden sie online auf heute.de
generaldebatte im bundestag zum haushalt
der kanzlerin traditionell ist es immer
eine aussprache über den kurs der
regierung die kanzlerin nutzte sie auch
für ein plädoyer gegen hass und hetze
die meinungsfreiheit ende da wo hass
verbreitet wird dagegen müsse man sich
stellen
dafür gab es sogar applaus von teilen
der opposition die ansonsten kein gutes
haar ließ an der regierungspolitik
lassen sagt berichtet es ist an der
grössten oppositionspartei die
generaldebatte zu eröffnen die afg hat
das klima für sich als thema entdeckt
und erklärt die politik der regierung
für gescheitert
denn die lage wirklich so schlimm ist
wenn wir wirklich demnächst auf diesen
schönen planeten gekocht werden
dann müssen zuerst sie sich wohl der
einsicht öffnen dass der populistische
atomausstieg ein irrweg war
die kanzlerin hält dagegen zählt aus
ihrer sicht die erfolge der groth nur
auf und verteidigt dabei dass erst vor
wochen beschlossene klimapaket land wie
deutschland ein prozent der
weltbevölkerung stellt und zwei prozent
der co2-emissionen verursacht
wer wenn nicht wir sollen zeigen dass es
geht dass man den klimawandel etwas
entgegensetzt
ich gebe ihnen ja absolut recht dass die
rolle der bundesrepublik deutschland
eines hochtechnologie landes zur
bekämpfung der klimakrise sein sollte
genau zu zeigen wie es geht
es stellt sich halt bloß die frage warum
machen sie das denn nicht die fdp
benennt schwarz-rote versäumnisse und
wirft der koalition vor die wirtschaft
zu gefährden
wer die wirtschaft links liegen lässt
darf sich über probleme von rechts
irgendwann nicht wundern
es sei nur die angst vor dem wähler der
die regierungspartner noch zusammen
schweiße so die linke eigentlich dürfte
man die zweite hälfte ihrer spielzeit
gar nicht mehr einfach ein pfeifen
spielabbruch und neue mannschaften wären
das beste überraschend heute das
demonstrative bekenntnis von union und
spd die koalition bis 2021 fortführen zu
wollen sozialdemokraten haben den
haushalt für 2020 geprägt und meine
fraktion will auch an dessen umsetzung
mitwirken deshalb finde ich
wir sollten die legislaturperiode lang
weiter habe meine persönliche meinung
ich bin dabei absicht
tatsächlich hängt der fortbestand der
gruppe oder von arten wer die spd
künftig führen wird in drei tagen gibt
die partei das ergebnis ihrer
mitgliederbefragung bekannt
hochaktuelles thema auf der herbsttagung
des bundeskriminalamts heute was tun
gegen hass kommentare im netz 2018
zählte das bka 1472 fälle die
dunkelziffer dürfte allerdings sehr viel
höher sein wir müssen klarmachen dass
hetze im netz konsequenzen hat sagte
bka-chef münch bislang müssen facebook
und co morddrohungen und volksverhetzung
löschen
künftig sollen sie das auch dem bka
melden dominik laux meister markus
nierth war bürgermeister von tröglitz in
sachsen-anhalt 2015 wollte er helfen
flüchtlinge in dem ort unterzubringen
es kam zu demonstrationen einem
brandanschlag auf das gebäude
er und seine familie wurden bedroht
jetzt trat zurück morddrohungen und hass
gegen politiker vor allem in den
sozialen medien nehmen sie zu verändern
das gesellschaftliche klima und das haus
wirklich ganze familien verunsichern
kann und soll schon andere welt wenn man
morddrohungen bekommt oder briefe die
mit kot gefüllt sind
dann trifft das dann kann man nach außen
noch so stark sein wie kann man hasst
kommentare im netz besser bekämpfen
thema der herbsttagung des
bundeskriminalamts in wiesbaden erst vor
kurzem hatte die bundesregierung ein
maßnahmenpaket beschlossen soziale
netzwerke wie facebook müssen künftig
morddrohungen und volksverhetzung dem
bka melden werden die strafbarkeit
prüfung durchführen wir werden über die
ip adressen wie google sachen die
verursacher ermitteln um dann das ganze
an die jeweils zuständigen stellen
weiterzuleiten
das klare signal muss sein
strafverfolgung findet im netz statt das
ist kein kein strafverfolgungsfreier
raum die ermordung des kasseler
regierungspräsidenten lübke war ein
weckruf hass kommentare ernst zu nehmen
denn sie sind ein brandbeschleuniger für
reale gewalt wir haben
gezieltes bespielen von beispielsweise
social media durch strategische akteure
von rechtsaußen die ihre botschaften die
sie sonst früher nur im kleineren raum
verbreiten können jetzt viel schneller
und viel leichter an eine ganz große
masse aussenden können
das bka will vor allem mehr personal
einsetzen hasskriminalität ist eine
herausforderung für die
sicherheitsbehörden und den rechtsstaat
immer noch keine heiße spur gibt es nach
dem einbruch ins grüne gewölbe in
dresden die polizei geht inzwischen
davon aus dass vier täter am werk waren
dies gehe aus dem videomaterial hervor
hieß es aktuell werden neben dem
bekannten video weitere
überwachungskameras ausgewertet bei der
sonderkommission seien insgesamt 205
hinweise aus der bevölkerung eingegangen
im vatikan gibt es einen finanzskandal
das hat papst franziskus jetzt
eingestanden es sind dinge passiert die
nicht sauber waren sagte er auf dem
rückflug von tokio nach rom
immerhin sei der fall diesmal aus der
kirche heraus aufgedeckt worden
spendengelder aus einer kollekte dem
sogenannten peterspfennig sollen in
verlustreiche immobiliengeschäfte in
london geflossen sein
gegen fünf mitarbeiter der kirche wird
ermittelt einen tag nach dem schweren
erdbeben in albanien suchen
rettungskräfte aus dem in und ausland
mit hochdruck nach verschütteten
immer wieder gelingt es ihnen
überlebende aus den trümmern zu ziehen
die zahl der todesopfer ist inzwischen
auf 29 gestiegen 650 menschen wurden
verletzt
über die situation im katastrophengebiet
berichtet britta hilpert
einmal den bagger anhalten signalisiert
der rettungsmann man muss hören ob da
noch wer ist aus ganz europa auch aus
deutschland kommt hilfe nach albanien
wichtigstes ziel aller ist es nun in den
trümmern noch überlebende zu finden
auch aus der schweiz sind sie mit einem
such und gekommen denn alle wissen es
ist jetzt ein wettlauf mit der zeit auch
lebend rechnungen möglich sind bestellt
immer noch und das ist sehr eindrücklich
zu sehen wie man dort den mut nicht
aufgibt alte feindschaften spielen in
der not keine rolle mehr
into mal helfen 13 serben aber aus dem
schutt können sie nur noch zwei tote
bergen
trotzdem wir danken allen helfern die
aus serbien kamen und aus all den
anderen ländern
die hilfs camps sinnvoll denn auch die
nachbeben sind heftig bis zur stärke 5,3
lieber verbringen sie eine weitere nacht
im freien als in angeschlagenen gebäuden
das haus in dem ich wohne ist ruiniert
sagt sie und auch dass die regierung
schuld sei weil die bauqualität zu wenig
kontrolliert würde über die ganze region
wurde nun ein 30 tägiger notstand
verhängt denn viele häuser stehen zwar
aber wie standhaft sie jetzt noch bei
nachbeben sind ist ungewiss
zurück nach deutschland der
bundesgerichtshof hat ein urteil gefällt
dass mieter und verbraucher freuen wird
online portale dürfen im namen von
verbrauchern etwa gegen mieterhöhungen
vorgehen für die kunden ist das
kostenlos und ohne risiko
anwälte hatten geklagt da sei eine
unzulässige rechtsberatung ist es nicht
sagt der bundesgerichtshof sah attacke
hat die details
ruhig und trotzdem mitten in der stadt
hier wohnen dass es begehrt und deshalb
kassieren vermieter oft mehr miete als
es die mietpreis bremse erlaubt dass
auch er zu viel zeit hat er geahnt knapp
1000 euro für 65 quadratmeter in berlin
im internet stößt boskovsky durch zufall
auf die plattform weniger miete de ein
paar klicks und schnell wird klar
wahrscheinlich zeit der jeden monat 2
130 euro mehr als er müsste die
plattform weniger miete de streitet
deshalb aktuell für ihn vor gericht
bezahlen muss er sie dafür aber nur bei
erfolg wenn sie gewinnen und dann auch
nur eine kleine provision
deswegen haben wir da eigentlich keine
kosten sondern verdienen an der
rückzahlung und sparen in zukunft an der
miete den mieter freut und die obersten
zivilrichter die haben heute auch ihr
okay gegeben entschieden dass die
online-plattform weniger miete de
weiterhin als inkasso firma und mit
erfolgshonorar arbeiten darf
erleichterung auch beim unternehmer
wir freuen uns sehr im namen unseres
eigenen unternehmens aber natürlich auch
für alle verbraucher und verbraucher in
deutschland jetzt geht's erst richtig
los denn die entscheidung hat
grundsätzliche bedeutung für viele
online portale und viele verbraucher ob
miete zu hoch flug zu spät oder internet
zu langsam es gibt viele neue online
portale die es verbrauchern ermöglichen
ihr recht gleich durchzusetzen und für
sie alle ist mit dieser
grundsatzentscheidung heute klar sie
dürfen weiterhin verbrauchern zu ihrem
recht verhelfen und das schnell einfach
und ohne kostenrisiko für die
verbraucher borowski atmet auf denn mit
dem urteil heute ist klar seine rechte
als mieter kann er leichter durchsetzen
hervorragende ideen für die wirtschaft
werden jährlich mit dem deutschen
zukunftspreis geehrt er ist dotiert mit
250.000 euro bundespräsident steinmeier
zeichnet in diesen minuten den gewinner
aus die firma cellonis aus münchen ihre
software identifiziert die
schwachstellen in den abläufen von
unternehmen und gibt empfehlungen zu
zdf zeigt die verleihung heute abend ab
22 uhr 15
und damit sind wir bei der sportlichen
personalie des tages nicht wirklich
überraschend aber auf jeden fall
spektakulär ex bundes- und
bayern-trainer jürgen klinsmann kehrt
zurück in die bundesliga
er löst hertha coach ante jobs ab und
wird bis saisonende in berlin arbeiten
die arbeit beginnt für jürgen klinsmann
heute nachmittag trainer bei hertha dem
verein zu dem er eine besondere
beziehung hat
ich hatte eine lange vorgeschichte auf
meinen vater der war begeistert sein war
mein erstes bundesligaspiel war
stuttgart gegen hertha da stand ich hing
da ist achtjähriger bub in einer kurve
mit einer blau weißen fahne für den
sommer märchen bundestrainer von 2006
ist es die zweite trainerstation in der
bundesliga nach dem glücklosen gastspiel
bei den bayern in der saison 2008/2009
klinsmann übernimmt den tabellen 15
in der krise das 0 4 in augsburg am
sonntag war berlins vierte bundesliga
niederlage nacheinander und für coach
das aus das allerwichtigste es aufgrund
der jetzigen konstellation ist nach oben
zu klettern
helfen sollen dabei ex werder bremen
coach alexander nouri als assistent und
andreas köpke als torwart-trainer seien
noch frischen posten als herta
aufsichtsrat für millionen investor lars
windhorst muss klinsmann ruhen lassen
solange er trainer ist ein job der ihm
trotz widriger umstände war spaß zu
machen scheint
zur fußball-champions-league gestern
abend da hat sich bayer leverkusen durch
einen 2 0-sieg bei lokomotive moskau
zumindest platz drei gesichert und ist
damit schon mal für die zwischenrunde
der europa league qualifiziert die
bayern dagegen die sind souveräner
gruppen-erster nach dem 6 0 sieg gegen
roter stern belgrad münchen stürmer
robert lewandowski mit vier toren in 14
minuten und 32 sekunden ein historischer
vierer pack 3 punkte und den spielball
mitgenommen aus belgrad die bayern haben
eindruck hinterlassen insbesondere ehe
robert lewandowski der torjäger mit
einer gala vorstellung in der zweiten
halbzeit 2 zu 0 53 bis spielminute 67
folgen die tore 2 3 und 4 des torjägers
der pole jetzt mit insgesamt 63 toren in
der champions league heute auch wieder
eine herausragende vorstellung von ihm
und ja ich weiß nicht was da noch für
rekorde knacken weil dies ja es scheint
mir auf jeden fall sehr motiviert zu
sein
goretzka der torschütze des ersten tores
nach 14 minuten deutlich so der des
sechsten und letzten die bayern eilen
von sieg zu sieg es ist der vierte
erfolg im vierten spiel unter trainer
flick am morgen abend treten sie dann
über hoffentlich auch erfolgreiche
leipziger und dortmunder die spielen ja
gleich es gibt menschen bei denen wächst
die spannung sekündlich nicht
vorenthalten wollen wir ihnen einen
kuriosen moment aus dem griechischen
fernsehen
ein reporter wird live ins studio
geschaltet und bekommt unerwartet
gesellschaft ein neues schwein das weder
licht noch kameras scheut und dem man
ziemlich auf die pelle rückt sehr zur
belustigung seiner kollegen im studio
die gewinnzahlen lauten 112 20 33 40 41
und die superzahl 9 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und im
zdf text auf seite 55 7
beim wetter wenig neues es bleibt windig
und regnerisch die details hat gleich
erst intern im heute journal spricht
marietta slomka mit der neuen eu
kommissionspräsident in ursula von der
leyen morgen begrüßt sie hier petra
gerster und wir wünschen ihnen noch
einen unbeschwerten abend machen sie es
gut auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
ein schöner abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter tiefer luftdruck
bestimmt unser wetter mit einem tief
über der nordsee was allmählich richtung
ostsee wandert und sie sehen hier es
kommt schon wieder kräftiger regen auf
und auf der alpensüdseite auch wieder
schnee
bis zum wochenende wird es kühler von
norden her 60 kalte luft durch und die
flutet einmal mittel europa sehen es
hier und auch in deutschland wird es
spürbar kälter
schauen wir in die nacht im westen
deutschlands viele wolken mit regen das
nächste regengebiet zieht hier rein
dazu gibt es viel wind und sturmböen bis
75 kilometer pro stunde sind möglich in
den höheren lagen ist der wind auch
stärker im osten ist es trocken
temperaturen sinken auf 2 grad im
südosten und 10 grad ganz im westen
deutschlands und morgen gibt es viele
wolken über deutschlands viel regen vor
allem im nordwesten dazu eben kräftiger
wind die sonne blinzelt mal richtung
sachsen raus aber insgesamt bleibt es
ziemlich dicht bewölkt bei temperaturen
von sieben grad am alpenrand und 13 grad
richtung neiße die nächsten tage gehen
noch nass weiter vor allem am freitag
recht kräftige regen vor allem im süden
fünf bis zehn grad und ab samstag wird
es kälter sehen es zwei bis acht grad
sonntag sogar nur noch 0 bis 6 grad
ein schöner abend